well as joe mentioned there terrell
rhodes was arrested and is now
charged with first-degree murder
continuing our coverage here at five
the i-team's vanessa murphy and vanessa
there were concerns about his safety
even his grandmother alluded to it
leading up to his death that's right
denise we've learned there may have been
warning signs that
amari nicholson was in danger sources
tell me within the past year there was
at least
one report made to child protective
services alleging abuse
and the agency looked into the
allegation but closed the case without
taking further
action i reached out to cps but a
spokesman says state law
prohibits them from discussing specific
individuals
as we first reported now terrell rhodes
is in jail
accused of killing the child do you
think
if cps had investigated
more after these calls you're saying the
family made do you
think omari would be safe right now yes
ma'am
he'd be just fine carrie howard is amari
nicholson's maternal grandmother
on monday she told the i-team loved ones
had been concerned about the safety of
the two-year-old child since his mother
started dating terrell rhodes last year
on tuesday sources told the eye team
rhodes confessed
to killing amari
are you mr rhodes the 27-year-old man
appeared in court for a murder charge
wednesday we would note that the
defendant lied for approximately one
week regarding covering up the
murders on may 7th amari's mother taylor
nicholson
and rhodes talked with 8 news now's joe
moeller rhodes was watching amari while
his mom was out of town
he claimed a woman calling herself an
aunt showed up to take the child
and as i'm going to call my girlfriend
and pack his bag at the same time she
says that
they already got everything that they
need for him then she
proceeded out the door but metro police
say rhodes later admitted to hitting
omaree numerous times which caused his
death on may 5th
two days before that interview and then
hid the child's body
according to the clark county district
attorney's office evidence includes
blood on a wall and soiled
child's clothing detectives say they
knew rhodes was their primary suspect
while rhodes continued to give his
version to 8 news now
what's really sickening is that people
is
making assumptions thinking that i have
something to do with it that
i have heard
manipulated in some way which
that's sickening to me also because
you love us i mean we we never do
nothing like that
police say rhodes fought with officers
and grabbed an
officer's gun when they went to arrest
him he will likely face charges in
connection with that incident
the i-team has learned rhodes was
released from prison last year
for robbery and burglary convictions
brian back to you
okay vanessa thank you for your
reporting on this